do this go nuts
your weapon sir will kill the ultimate
forged in fire match-up you are the
forest and fire Champion two Champion
planes in a deadly weapon Showdown it
will kill 20 blades 20 Champions you
decide the winner forged in fire Madness
this is a Musketeers rape your Jesse
Ewing's my name 34 years old and I kill
bugs for a living Pest Control good
stuff
I know that to come on Forge and fire is
a huge undertaking however I know that I
have the skills and passion to go all
the way originating in the early 1600s
the Musketeers Rapier was the
distinctive weapon of the colorful
French Musketeers of the Guard
these Elite troops were the first line
of defense for French royalty featuring
a thin Diamond profile blade that tapers
down to a point it's extreme lightweight
made it excellent for Quake slashing
cuts and pinpoint stabs
in addition the weapons double clam
shell guard aided in defense by
protecting the user's hand especially
during one-on-one duels tales of the
swashbuckling Musketeers are world
famous to this day and can be seen in
the film The Three Musketeers
[Music]
the flambear's Rapier my name is Dave
parthmore I'm a bitten spur maker it's
like jewelry for horses as a metal
worker you pretty much wear every hat
hopefully I'll do well I would hate to
go out there and make a fool of myself
the flambear's Rapier was popular in
Europe from the mid 17th century through
the early 18th century as an ornate
stylized gentleman's sword rapiers were
light agile weapons that could be
wielded single-handed to precisely
administer pinpoint stabs and cuts the
undulating double-edged blade design
increased the length of the cutting
surface while frustrating an opponent's
attempts to slide his weapon closer to
the wielder's hands today you can see
the flambear's Rapier in the hit mobile
strategy game dominations
I'm taking on the musketeer Rapier
I'm gonna go with far stock size of
adcrv tube super strong should hold up
very well to the testing that's going to
be the hardest part because I don't know
what it has to survive
finches total length which gives me
plenty of room for error I think I'm
going to start working on the Fuller
oh
I can't complain about that my first
ever Fuller with all the factors
involved in this quench the low roof of
the garage the tall quench tank a ladder
just to breach above it
I'm hoping that I can get it right the
first time
catastrophically the sword drops out of
my hands I hear the tip hit the bottom
of the tank I pull the sword out of the
quench I see this huge bow
I gotta get this thing in my
straightening jig I have no idea what's
going to come out I'm really scared I'm
really nervous hoping for the best and
praying for a miracle
so the swords cooled off in the
straightening jig let's see if I just uh
performed a miracle here it's time to
open it up and see what's inside
crap
there's slight warpage on there but
nothing crazy that I can't fix with a
grinder
she's hard I've never made a sword
before so I'm ecstatic right now so with
my blade mostly done and I've already
got the clamshell guard fitted out guard
fits for this handle I'm going to go
with a nice hardwood and offset that
with different color Micarta and then
epoxy together so I can shape it off of
the sword oh gosh I go to remove the
handle and she's stuck
I really don't know what the heck to do
at this point
seriously contemplating taking this
thing to the bandsaw and I look at The
Sword and the rear part is separated
I think I can save this
try it again second time imagine that
and that's how it should have went the
first time
yeah that came together pretty nice with
the time I got left I'm gonna start
shaping all these quillians and knuckle
bows and all that fruit stuff on the
handles
the blade itself I'm pretty much happy
with the geometry of it but I want to
see if I can remove some weight at the
tip I want Doug to be swinging that
thing all over the place and having a
good time with it
everything's permanently affixed just
gotta clean it up sharp it up a little
bit
I can't wait to see the judges test this
thing
we're here at my Forge in Connecticut
let's go move some steel
we take this hunk of Steel and get it in
shape and with my equipment it's a slow
process but it's an accurate process
with a Ply press you really have a sense
of what the metal is doing
you're not just relying on your eyes
you're relying on your feel touch you
could say there's an intimacy
as a metal worker if you need a g or a
tool you make it you build it this is my
jig just a bunch of nipples from large
to small I'm going to create my
serpentine or my Blade with these
I set this up for the serpentine to
begin wide so it's shaped like a very
narrow Christmas tree all the way up
there's your Serpentine blade I need to
do a little dressing up on my basket
help I'm going to flame blue this piece
so it has a nice uniform color to it
now I need to get my counterbalance on
the back end that Pummel that is really
key because you have so much material
hanging out in front you've got to have
that counterweight in the back end you
could have a heavy blade as long as it's
balanced I have a cut I squared it and
now I'm attempting to tap it so I can
thread it onto the Tang of the sword
ah I didn't want that to happen
oh boy I forced it and uh
the tap snapped
not a good thing my brain's going a
million miles an hour so I grabbed a
larger piece of stock it's mild Steel
should be much easier to work with raise
the weight a little bit but I need that
counterbalance for it to function
properly it's stabby it'll stab
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
take your rapierce and deliver some
killing slashes and thrusts on this big
carcass for these musketeer swords it's
time to find out if you're all for one
Champion or one for all the runner-ups
just here up first you ready for this
let's cut some bacon all right let's do
this
to be chopping into a full-size Pig this
is crazy I'm worried because there's
bones inside that pig but at this point
it's in the judge's hands and I can't
wait to see what happens
dude
you gotta work out
all right Jesse this Edge
is sharp a rape here kind of big in half
that's very interesting
for every slash The Edge lands exactly
where I want it to be okay over also for
this test
it's a little cute
all right David it's your turn you ready
I'm ready yes sir let's do this
my blade may be a little sexier Maybe
but performance is everything
[Music]
bacon nice job man that looks beautiful
all right Dave the balance of this blade
allows it to be able to be maneuvered
quite easily on the thrusting easy
penetration all the way and on slashing
it cut spine and even deeper into the
flesh overall sir your blade will kill
thank you sir
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test little thing I like to
call the wheel of pain
now a Rapier needs to be a fast light
flexible weapon we're going to see how
flexible yours are
all right Jesse so I've got your blade
strapped into our wheel of pain right
now now I'm going to be flexing it in
both directions I'll be taking it all
the way to that far red Peg
holding it for about three seconds and
we'll see if it comes back true and then
we'll go in the other direction all
right go nuts
that ship sailed
so my Blade's strapped into this crazy
machine that's about to get pulled and
pushed and bent Beyond its limits and
I'm freaking out you've got your
precious baby that you've worked so hard
on right there and ten thousand dollars
on the other side of it
[Music]
foreign
are you kidding me
okay Jesse
first off remarkable but I mean there's
a lot of weight in this blade a lot of
mass so to have it flexed the way it did
and come back virtually to true this
blade is still straight enough to fight
with which is excellent thank you good
job thank you all right metal workers to
test the strength and overall
construction of your blade I'll be
attacking these Steel bucklers remember
this test is not about what your blades
do to the bucklers but what those
bucklers can do to your blades all right
Dave you ready yes sir okay
so Dave first off everything could be
about 20 percent smaller having said
that the balance point is right there in
between those two fingers which is what
I want because now I can control the tip
I don't really feel
any damage it flexed very well and came
back to true
very good job thank you so much
thank you now it's your turn which
weapon will you choose forged in fire
Madness